this idea this first principle money is
really really crucial really what it's
worth memorizing I had a lot of trouble
memorizing this when I was in year 11
because I don't think I really got that
what it comes from is just rise over run
that's it okay it's just rise everyone
in a particular case namely when I'm
looking at two points that are just a
smidgen apart right and we call the
smidgen edge and we want the smidgen to
get very very very smaller okay so rise
over run
okay we're further that's your diagram
make sure you've got a good one here and
your first page when you're introduced
and said now I got the question give it
to me does this only work with parabolas
yeah I guess is a special case - I need
a different rule or a different way of
approaching different kinds of functions
answers merit the great thing about
first principles because it's just very
simply about rise over run it'll work on
anything anything okay so we're gonna
stop I don't want to go through all too
quickly so let's treat functions that
are similar to the ones game okay I gave
you x squared
strikes cute let's let let's let f of X
equal x cute okay
we're gonna get a result from this and
then we try and interpret it what it for
what it means geometrically so from here
this definition right I'm just
substituting points in okay if that's
what F is let's work out F - our
gradient function okay by the way I
always just on submission do I have to
write this limit thing all the time
do I have to put it out front every
single line and the answer is yes the
question is why why can I just leave it
off after a little while or like just
reinsert it back at the end does anyone
remember what's the difference between
this and just putting it there without
the without the limit what's the
difference
exactly right yeah it'll be close right
it'll be sort of an approximation but I
can't say it equals I'd have to say to
be like almost okay so if I wanna if
when I get the precise gradient function
f dash then I've got to have this limit
business out the front every time okay
just right you mean you mean like this
is a symbol for memory well I think
because this is number one because this
is meaningful it means something number
two the limit isn't always gonna
approach zero right where are we gonna
look at different limits different
variables like when X is doing something
or Y etcetera etcetera okay so all right
what does this actually look like in the
case of X cubed well f of X plus h that
means every way see you next put an X
plus h right so do we X plus h or tubed
- that's f of X and I'll be all dividing
by H now you saw before my goal was to
work with this algebraically and feel
such a point that I can get rid of this
denominator and then I can actually put
in H equals zero so what's it gonna look
like well on the top here okay you get
have to expand this return me it it's a
cubic it's a little bit curse yeah we
get to that one in a second I don't want
to confuse people too much - what victor
Sorna is is more than one way stay first
principle okay and I'll get to it we'll
get to it but I just wanted to tackle
one first principles first this is first
principles
okay what's the expansion if you want
you can don't do X plus h times X with H
squared and then you can span that again
I'll save is for time it should be X
cubed plus 3x squared h plus 3x h
squared plus h cubed if that looks very
orderly to you the reasonable why is
because it is and we'll talk all the
reasons why it looks so
being sensible and where are these
threes came from when we tackle a topic
called binomial theorem but that's for
next year anyway that's - execute okay
so all of this is divided by H as you
can see we've got something very similar
we had before these two terms will
cancel minus X cubed and X cubed okay
because I can see that right I'm
actually going to skip a step I think
you can too I'm going to divide all of
these by H right away because I can see
those will cancel so I'll have the limit
at the front okay all these guys with
one less H each time so I'll have the
first one be 3x squared the second one
will be 3x H and this last one will be H
squared okay by the way I think it is
important to put these brackets around
rather than leaving it like this because
this does actually imply you're just
taking the limit of the first thing and
these are the guys are doing something
else later on we will get separate
limits which you have to treat is two
different things so I think it's
important to make it clear this is just
one limit okay now well having gotten
rid of the H on the denominator I can
say well when H approaches zero
what will this thing become also zero
when H approaches zero
what will this do McCarthy also zero
right what will be left with is this
term which if you like is independent of
H ok so it sticks around so you get 3x
squared okay what does this mean this is
all about what your gradient remember
what does X cube look like
okay what's going on here this is my
function f of X is x squared X cubed
sorry so all of this first principles
work told me that if I want to know the
gradient at any particular point this is
the function that defines the gradient
that's all we call it the gradient
function so again let's think about some
values here right at x equals zero here
what's the green in equal to it'll be 3
times 0 squared which is 0 which is what
you'd expect it's horizontal there right
what about a point over here like say x
equals 1
ok at x equals 1 the greater reach 3
times 1 squared which is 3 it's
increasing okay
reason quite quickly if I put in bigger
values of X like 2 3 4 5 it gets more
and more steep no way it's really funny
interesting is when you think about the
left-hand side okay you put in negative
numbers it's pretty minus 1 the grain
will be 3 times minus 1 squared which is
just 3 which is positive actually it's
exactly you'd expect and that's why as
you put in the gradient from different
points right when you think about it
symmetrically this is an odd function ok
so the gradient on each side is equal
right the the gradient is get this odd
function even gradient you see that ok
now this - what's this looks for
anything
ok let's let's do another example
quickly do you mean yeah yeah ok
the answer is No however if I if I were
to do that right let's just put in an
intermediate life ok what is the limit
as H approaches 0 of 3 x squared well
because this has an H has no impact on 3
x squared right
it'll just be 3x squared ok which is why
I had this point needed vanishes this
really is what it's equal to
when H is infinitesimally small all
right let's do one more and then you
start to be getting frustrated at this
whole idea of first
okay and I will get rid of it for a time
what if we get set the power up one more
okay and by the way you will be asked to
do things from first principles and this
is about as as large as the numbers get
because it starts to get a bit
ridiculous after this the algebra what's
the derivative we start with the limit
okay and then you've got this thing here
okay now by the way um I actually do
think it's worth particularly start
quoting the whole of first principles
before you actually start any working no
because they don't get any clocks but
because it'll help you learn first
principles the next line is I'm actually
going to put it into excellent form okay
so that's X plus h all to the four minus
X okay again I'll save you some time
that you couldn't if you like you can
expand this out and verify my result
this is going to be a limit of X to the
four plus four x cubed H plus six x
squared but do these numbers look
familiar at all okay all of this is
divided by H okay again same kind of
patting X to the four minus X to the
four and women left with is all of these
terms in here the limit as H approaches
your alt less one H
that's one that's one and so all these
terms 1 2 3 they're all approach 0
because they've got the Asian or you're
left with is this independent term so
this point hopefully your mathematical
instincts are getting suspicious
right because Matz is all about patterns
right and seeing them and taking
advantage of them so when we have F and
then we looked at its derivative there's
another word for gradient function when
we had x squared we got its us when we
got X cubed we got through 3x squared
all right next to the 4 we had 4 X kids
can you guess one X to the 5 ah
so therefore could you explain to me if
we were trying to generalize stick a
number in there and what's going on this
power right becomes the coefficient of
your new grading function and then what
happens to the power
drops by one okay so here this is what
we call the rule for differentiating
polynomials things were the power on
them okay you could tell me what's the
derivative the great function R of X to
the hundredth if you like it pretty
simple
hundred comes out the front and the
power drops by one now question what if
I have the square root of x now this is
X to the 1/2 is an F so what would you
expect to happen you would expect that
the index the power to come out the
front and then you would expect the
numbers to reduce by 1 right so the new
power would be now how could you verify
I mean this seems to me because all
these are all on this right how could
you prove whether this was true or not
true answer and I'd like you to have
good treat is the square root of x ok
you might get of confuses you have to go
in it I want you to try it see how far
you can get